I remember the specific reason reasons
why I want to become a doctor this is
going to sound a little foolish maybe
and I said this numerous times before
but it was the TV show Ben Casey when i
was a kid i guess it was i was maybe 10
8 9 10 11 12 in that range i used to
watch Ben Casey and I thought that he
was the absolutely coolest person I ever
saw right and he did things for people
and he he was able to accomplish things
make people better and sometimes not
being people better but it was a very
powerful experience for me as a kid and
they stayed with me now you may recall
at that time back in the early 60s there
was another show a doctor show dr.
Kildare so you had been casing and dr.
Kildare I didn't like dr. Kildare that
much but I like Ben Casey right that's
what really kind of turned me on to it
now I'm going to fast-forward 40 years
later and my assistant longtime
assistant my birthday two years ago got
me the all the Ben Casey episodes on DVD
and I have to tell you I watched the
number of them brought back fond
memories but Ben Casey is not the doctor
that I wanted to be that's for sure it's
a whole different model of being a
physician first of all he's a chief
resident a neurosurgery at a County
Hospital but he seems like he's running
the whole hospital right now chief
residents don't run hospitals in
addition he is the most out of touch in
terms of human emotions and what you
have to do to talk to people and
recognize their feelings and emotions
that you can imagine occasionally
there's this flash of light that you see
some empathy and humanity at him but for
the most part he's got kind of a
brooding you know stereotypical surgeon
you know no tolerance for anybody
yelling yet the nurses you know it was
really not ultimately right not the
physician I or anybody else should
really be